or from lebanon to neighbouring israel
protests against prime minister benjamin
netanyahu there show
no signs of dying down for weeks
demonstrators have been taking to the
streets
demanding netanyahu resign over alleged
corruption and
the government's handling of the
coronavirus pandemic dw's tanya kremer
joined protesters in jerusalem who say
the long-term prime minister
must go enough is enough says haley
silverman
she came from tel aviv to jerusalem
several times to take part in
anti-government protests
she's fed up with the government and
israel's long-term prime minister benimi
netanyahu
i personally don't like bibi so i would
like him out
but more importantly i just want to
stable government for all of us
the world is going nuts right now how
are the people that are supposed to work
for us to represent us
they're not taking care of us so we
can't sit back
the country is in the midst of the
corona virus pandemic
but that has not stopped a few hundred
demonstrators gathering outside the
prime minister's residence
protests have been going on for weeks
calling on the premier to resign over
his indictment on corruption charges
there's also angered the government's
response to the coronavirus pandemic
rising unemployment and eroding
democracy
i've basically been against anything
this government has done for a long time
and finally there is an awakening
especially of the young generation
i support them i'm worried for my
children's future
i feel like many young people in israel
and around the world feel
like the whole democratic system and our
politicians and government
really they don't it's not a ideological
matter it's a leadership matter they
really don't care about us
directly opposite the protest some
liquid supporters show their solidarity
for the prime minister
and i came here to support db netanyahu
and to stand up against all this
anti-democratic
act because
bibi netanyahu was elected in a
democratic process
netanyahu has called the demonstrators
anarchists and leftists
not everybody in israel supports the
protests
for the younger generation there's a lot
more at stake
we're angry about everything we're angry
about having an
insignificant government that can't even
pass a budget bill on time
we're facing a fourth election because
they don't know how to run
the government they don't know how to
take care of us or they're just not
willing to
anti-government protests like this one
have been going on for weeks now
people are on the streets several times
a week
not just here in jerusalem close to the
prime minister's residence
but also throughout the country there's
no end inside this weekend
another big protest in jerusalem is
expected
you